So what are the best ways to detoxify past vaccines I've had? I've started. I'm starting to
read more and more about the dangers of these that I've foolishly had. Well, the best way to detoxify
vaccines, go back to everybody has access to the seven phases of detox course. So we all want
like a quick fix. I just want, what is, what should I take? You know, what, what's the magic supplement
for this or that or killing parasites or getting rid of vaccines? It's just not that simple. So you
need to support all the detox pathways. So it's really important for me not to give that simple
fix like, well, just take zero light or you just need EDTA as a key later or you just need to take,
you know, full of a acid. It's not that simple and it's, it would be inappropriate for me to say that
because you have to support all those pathways. You got to make sure you're having good bowel
movements daily bowel movements and you're really emptying your gut. You got to make sure that you're
binding things in the gut that's phase five, phase six was the bowel movements. You got to make sure
that your bile isn't blocked and that you got good bowel movement and your bile is not super viscous.
So you have good bile function, good gallbladder function, that's phase four. You got to make sure
that you're creating bile so that you are able to to bind toxins from the liver that you're trying to
pull out of other parts in your body. That's phase three and phase one and two were the main detoxification
phases that we look at when we look at your genetics. So we look at your genes. Do we need to support
the side of protein for 50 pathways and or the pod pathways and the NAT pathways, etc. That's phase one
and phase two, how you actually take toxins from your blood through your liver to help break them
down into soluble water soluble forms distributed into the bile and then get it in through the bile
duct to the gallbladder that dumped into the duodenum that it goes out and doesn't get reabsorbed
and gets into the toilet. So then when you got that all working correctly then you could work on
doing some chelation therapy to grab it out of the tissues in a way that's not going to just spill
it elsewhere in the blood and cause all sorts of symptoms. You got to go slow with that. So it is a
process. You you've had a process of becoming toxic. It's going to be a process of detoxified.
It's not a matter of I did this Bronx detox for two weeks. Now I detoxified.
No, you're constantly being toxified. So you have to be constantly detoxified. So your level of
toxicity is equal to your level of toxic exposure minus your ability to get rid of it. So you're
constantly working on that. We live in a toxic world and we're constantly dealing with this. So
go to the course to help you understand that. And you know we can't be pulling a whole bunch
of stuff out of the tissue when we're trying to kill cancer too because we could be spilling stuff.
We have to be careful and do this slowly.